I guarantee you that at some point
everything's gonna go south on you
and you're gonna say this is it this is
how I end
Marcus dead now you can either accept
that or you can get to work this will
come as quite a shock to my crewmates
and to NASA the end of the entire world
but I'm still alive surprise here's the
rub it's gonna be four years for another
mission to reach me and I'm in a hab
designed to last 31 days so I got to
make water and grow food on a planet
where nothing growth but if I can't
figure out a way to make contact with
NASA none of this matters anyway I've
got an incoming message my mom is still
alive Wow
in your face Neil Armstrong
okay so let's do the math I have enough
food to last for 50 days he's going to
starve to death long before we can help
myself I'm gonna have to science the
[ __ ] out of it there's 50 million miles
away from home he's totally alone the
hell is he thinking right now I am the
greatest botanist on this planet I know
how to save Mark Watney but we need to
Hermes crew we're gonna have a high
chance of killing one or a low chance of
36 I'm not risking their lives it's
bigger than one person No
Maseo rejected the mission so if we do
this we're talking with mutiny anything
goes wrong you realize how crazy the
stands
we had no other option
no matter what happens
tell the world
tell my family
never stop fighting
this [ __ ] an official is lapa van my
name is Mark Watney going to sleep now
often the